all right so we've got a little bit more
on the White House Correspondents Dinner
uh over the weekend uh we told you that
WNBA star Brittany Greiner and her wife
shirelle were special guests of CBS News
and everyone was excited to see the
three of them including Gail she is in
La this morning joining us hey
good evening
America hi Michelle hi Michelle Wide
Awake yeah well I'm not wide awake I
think my face is still in the hotel
sleeping but I am here listen it's just
five of us in the studio it is so weird
to be here with just five people and
myself it's very quiet so I'm so glad to
see you guys but let's talk about
Brittany and Sherelle Greiner you are so
right Vlad I couldn't stop smiling I
think my face hurt smiling so much
number one I thought it made us a cool
people's table because everybody wanted
to come over and say hello to the two of
them Brittany and Charelle were so
gracious everybody wanted to take a
picture everybody wanted to know how she
was doing and at one point I asked him
are you guys tired of this is this too
much Brittany said no I'm just so glad
to be around people and how do you not
feel good when everybody just wants to
embrace you and show you love I was very
honored that they they agreed to sit at
the CBS table there is a listen Brittany
took this picture your guy she said you
know because somebody else was trying to
do the selfie and she said let me do it
because my arm is like a selfie stick
what happened when she met a president
but you're right I would have never said
that about you but you're right you have
very long arms yeah okay so so they had
a private meeting with President Biden
and Joe Biden that was the first time
that they had met you know you just
assumed that the two of them had
connected and she said that she it felt
uh Lindsay who represents him said that
the president lit up like a Christmas
tree when Brittany and shirelle walked
in the room he said he was a big fan of
hers was glad to see her and Brittany
said I hope my head doesn't get a little
too big she as you know guys she is
lovely it was so good to see her in
person and talk talk to her she's lovely
and so gracious
yeah she was incredible it was
incredible having her as a guest at CBS
News uh speaking of big fans Gail you've
got some big fans you got a big award
over you got a big award Gail was saying
congratulations because after the dinner
you were honored with the grios
journalist icon award what did that feel
like well number one that scares me a
bit the I word scares me because I never
see myself that way you know I was on
the stage I don't I got to share the
stage with Diana Ross well she was on
first and then I came on after so we
were never on at the same time that to
me is a true icon you know it's the Grio
Awards and grios you know means
Storyteller and that really is how I see
myself and then right after that yeah I
see myself as a Storyteller I love
telling stories as we all do as we all
do
um after that Roy Wood Jr took the stage
he killed it he killed it at the party
he killed it both times
yeah he really did he's getting so did
you Gales congratulations all right
let's talk about the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame this morning The Rock Hall
revealed its 2023 inductees in the
category of performers they are Kate
Bush love me some Kate Bush Cheryl Crow
Missy Elliott that's why we're playing a
little missy earlier at the top George
Michael Willie Nelson Rage Against the
Machine and the Spinners oh I love the
Spinners yeah uh all right let me talk
about the musical influence award that
will be given to DJ Cool Hearth hip-hop
innovator who of course contributed to
the genre's early development in the
1970s and guitarist link Ray all know
Rumble
[Laughter]
[Music]
the musical Excellence award will go to
Chaka Khan we know Chaka Khan right all
right uh right
producer songwriter Al Cooper and Bernie
top and of course Elton John's long time
hit making collaborator the Ahmed
erdogan award will go to Soul Train
creators oh train Don Cornelius uh the
30th annual Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
induction ceremony will be on November
3rd in Brooklyn New York okay
it's a good list right it's quite the
party except we didn't get the guitar we
have to work on that okay we let you
down there's a great moment in a
documentary that he did about guitar
players where he's listening to it and
it takes him back to you know Jimmy Page
one of the great rock and roll guitars
was influenced as were many other
guitars by link Ray yeah and Vlad is
also a great guitarist he really is
you're really into the May the fourth be
with you going back to the very first
year that the movie came out I have a
picture of myself uh at a birthday party
in the mustard yellow t-shirt and the
burnt sienna burnt sienna jeans
um wearing that Star Wars t-shirt great
actually I gotta say that that was like
the like the um discount bin version I
wanted a Darth Vader t-shirt yeah I
could only get a C-3PO one
um but we love seeing ingredients for
pictures exactly live your childhood
yeah May the fourth be with you and also
with you
I don't know what do I do is that what
you do does it kill you is that a good
thing yeah you're done okay
sorry all right let's begin here we've
got the first
um you guys how old are you I played
Sports I play Modern Gail I'm the same
age that I was I get it I get it I get
it I get it let's start with the very
first comments we've uh received from
Jamie Foxx since he was hospitalized
last month this is good news his
daughter says the 55 year old Oscar
winner suffered a medical emergency more
than three weeks ago now we still don't
know why he was hospitalized but
yesterday this Instagram message on his
account told his fans quote appreciate
all the love feeling blessed I feel good
about that right yeah good to hear yes a
separate post thank Nick Cannon for
filling in as the host of his game show
it's called Beach Shazam while he
recovers yeah we don't know what's
what's happened we just all know we want
him to get better sooner rather than
later yes
we love you we absolutely do uh all
right
saddle up for a major shake-up at the
Dutton you get it Saddle Up
according to entertainment you're
cracking yourself up
actually our writers that crack me up
according to Entertainment Tonight Kevin
Costner will not return to the hit
series Yellowstone after its current
Fifth Season saying it so the 60 year
old Euro of course plays John Dutton
head of the family at the center of the
Paramount Network drama in the latest
season he took on a new role as
Montana's governor
well I'm not a politician
this was never my plan
my only plan was to preserve my family's
way of life
the land where they make it
the fact that you're
the fact that you're sitting here the
fact that you voted for a man who does
not want this job to lead this state
means we share the same goals yeah
well if we've all read there's been a
lot of behind the scenes tension behind
Kevin Costner and the show's co-creator
that's Taylor Sheridan including
disagreements about the filming schedule
for the season five uh the remaining
episode of course Yellowstone has
several star-studded spin-offs including
1883 which stars there you see Sam
Elliott 1923 with Harrison Ford and
Helen Mirren Tony you spoke to Helen
Mirren about that two more are in the
works Costner has not commented on the
report that he's leaving of course
Paramount network is owned by Paramount
our parent company and then yesterday he
announced that he and his wife close to
18 years are getting a divorce I was
very sorry to hear that yeah he's a lot
going on with Kevin he's going he's
going through some things although
quitting your job breaking up with your
partner is it a good thing or a bad
thing it depends on your point of view
he might be on his plan he might be on a
kind of Walkabout year no no no no no I
mean you never know no I never know what
he wants I don't know what he wants here
but we're going to miss him if he's not
going to play John Denver yes tell us
where you're going fishing let's talk
about the Kentucky Derby which will run
for the 149th time tomorrow under a
shadow of controversy famed trainer Safi
Joseph Jr was suspended indefinitely
yesterday he trained two of the four
horses that died at Churchill Downs in
the past week Bill Mudd the president of
Churchill Downs Incorporated announced
the track is suspending Joseph until
details about the sudden horse death are
analyzed and understood he says quote
the safety of our equine and human
athletes and integrity of our sport is
our highest priority Joseph's horse Lord
miles was scratched from the Derby as
part of the suspension the trainer told
local TV station WDRB that he is a
scapegoat yeah look he says I've run 3
800 horses in the races never had horses
die from this issue before so
investigations right it is something
troubling that's right yeah there's an
investigation
all right let's talk about our friend
Drew Barrymore and an extraordinary
thing that she is doing so the actor and
talk show host announced that she's
pulling out as host of Sunday's MTV
movie and TV Awards the reason to show
support for the members of The Writers
Guild of America who began their strike
this week Barrymore says I have listened
to the writers everything we celebrate
and honor about movies and television is
born out of their creation and until a
solution is reached I am choosing to
wait oh Drew Barry yes uh the executive
producer of the award show Bruce Gilmer
told variety they fully respect and
support Barrymore the show will go on
without a host Barrymore says she'll be
ready to host next year the awards uh
the award show Will Go On Without a red
carpet interview beforehand and MTV like
cbs's own by Paramount Global excited
about doing it too she's very clearly
looking forward I love her showing
support and solidarity to the writers
because whatever you may think about
what's going on just remember that with
the actors directors producers
cinematographers it all begins with the
original on the page it all begins on
the page they have walked hand in hand
with Drew throughout her career that's
right her showing the solidarity it's
good just for the people that's right
exactly and they've made some very valid
points the writers have and if there's
anybody who can take a stand on this
it's not just acting Legend Drew
Barrymore she comes from a long line of
actors going back to the 19th century
she knows a little bit about what she's
talking about of course I love you drew
yeah all right Formula One racing fans
including Gail King might spot because
Gail's a formula one fact I am yeah did
you guys not know that you gotta leave
for Speed I love Lewis Hamilton I know
you do so you might spot a famous
Hollywood face behind the wheel this
summer in the grand tradition of actors
ranging from Elvis Presley and Steve
McQueen to Chris Hemsworth and Christian
Bale Brad Pitt yeah we'll be shooting
racing scenes at the British Grand Prix
in July wow it's for new I know it's
pretty cool it's for a new movie being
produced by Jerry here's Louis Hamilton
and and seven time Formula One World
Champion Lewis Hamilton uh Brooke Heimer
and the director confirmed that Pitt
will drive an F1 car but he will not
race against other drivers because you
know he's an actor well but I'm mean
these are not it's not like driving a
regular car right no no no it's not like
driving a regular car but he's not
racing he's pretending to be a racist
yeah but look how many people now want
to go to the British Grand Prix I know
that's true that's true Gail everybody's
very incredible see Brad Pitt uh all
right let's talk about the late Carrie
Fisher who was honored with the star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame yesterday the
unveiling fittingly took place on May
the 4th which as you all know is Star
Wars Day her daughter Billy Lord and
Mark Hamill also known as Luke Skywalker
they were there to celebrate and so were
C-3PO and R2D2 Fisher who died in 2016
was of course best known for her role as
the Beloved Princess Leia her daughter
spoke about her Legacy
Leia is more than just a character she's
a feeling she has strength she is Grace
she is a wit she has femininity at its
finest people's love for Leia didn't die
with my mom it continues to get passed
on from generation to generation just
like my mom passed it on to me and I am
now passing it on to my children and
hopefully they will pass it on to theirs
so even though I'm a huge Star Wars fan
I also want to recognize that Carrie
Fisher was an actor in many many other
films including the Blues Brothers and
Hannah and her sisters and When Harry
Met Sally and she wrote a book Postcards
From The Edge she's the daughter of
acting Legend uh Debbie Reynolds and
Eddie Fisher the singer so she had she
was multi-talented multifaceted yeah
there was so much more to her than me
than just Princess Leia exactly and may
the fourth be with it was a role that
defined a generation it really was
though isn't that how it goes May the
fourth be with you may the fourth be
with you but it's based on May the force
be oh okay yeah made the force the
forces I think it flows through us all
it finds us